right
I have to tell you something really
important's going to change the course
of history and stuff this egg is filled
with the blood of our Lord and Savior
Jesus Christ there's one of seven
powerful eggs and all of them are in the
hands of Satan's number one egg finder
Dean a hunter are you listening I'm
listening I have a very particular set
of skills skills that have not served me
very well in protecting this egg so I
have to pass along to you Nell you were
the chosen one nothing will ever be the
same again and stuff would be good what
do you mean I'm the chosen one you are
the chosen you I was chosen I failed
you're the chosen one now but I'm not
good enough to be the chosen one I just
heard about this when the time comes
you'll know exactly what to do you
listen everything I've just don't you
yeah all right guard the egg keep it
keep it safe with great power comes
great responsibility you're a wizard
Harry use your powers to protect this
egg from Satan and the destruction of
the world as
can you do this can you do this we'll do
it
wait so if you had the egg and the egg
hunters coming this way the egg hunters
coming this way
yeah I didn't know where else to go what
does that mean what am I gonna do when
she gets here no hit on her or something
usually guys you boy don't have to fight
her that's for you to figure out I'm
losing a lot of what what happened your
throat the egg the egg Hunter did that
yeah do that sucks
yeah like totally painful stuff no Jerry
don't die on me I'm dying right I'm
right
no I can see George Lucas no blood loss
Fox I will kill you a quarter kill yeah
and tell Maria hi
I'm gonna kill this [ __ ]
so you must be the egg hunter
are you looking for this
if you want that AG you're gonna have to
go through me but we're gonna have to do
that in the garage
you can walk for a long time this is my
force
Oh
you [ __ ] up the wrong eggs
you're supposed to bash
well that takes care of the demon Jerry
Brian all the life the Lord Jesus is
real
you